(loud intense drumming)
- Good morning believe nation.
Today we're going to talk about
how you can be more present
and mindful.
Rule number four is my personal favorite,
and make sure to stick
around all the way to the end
for my thought and some
special bonus clips as well.
Also, as people are talking,
if they say something
that really resonates with you,
please leave it in quotes
and put it in the comments
down below so other people
can be inspired as well.
Enjoy.
(inspiring peaceful music)
(soft rhythmic music)
- When I'm playing
football, I appreciate it.
I'm nowhere else, I'm in the present.
That's probably the best
part about my life is
that to be in the present,
you talk about how do
you enjoy your life,
how do you find balance?
It's to live in the
present, to live like a kid.
Why do kids have so much fun?
Because they just care
about what they're doing.
- Yeah.
- And if we thought about what
we were doing all the time,
you do that when you're
on the football field.
It's probably the only place
that I can really do that,
when I really truly am my authentic self.
I mean, a lot of people see
it, my close, close friends do.
But when I'm on the football
field, it's just raw.
(soft rhythmic music)
- Number one, start out learning
to observe where you are,
and what I mean by that is mindfulness.
While we all think it's a
meditative trick up here,
and we'll talk about
meditation, it's great,
but as much as we think of
mindfulness as the mind,
I like to think about it
too, as the full activation
of your senses in the moment.
What that means is, a lot
of people, they'll walk into
a restaurant, they'll see their friend,
they'll walk over to their
friend, they'll sit down,
they'll eat a meal and everything,
but they never actually
looked around the restaurant.
You never smelled the
smells in the restaurant,
they never breathe the
air in the restaurant
sort of intentionally,
and so they were really in
the environment or the situation.
We've learned to block
out distractions so much
so that we can focus.
We've also learned to block out then life.
So observe where you are,
bring your full senses
to your next experiences.
Observation of the setting, the context.
Where am I right now?
What's the color of the walls?
What's it smell like here?
What's it feel like here?
What's this environment?
Human beings, we do have
a natural ability to pay
attention to our environment.
I want you to activate
that again, consciously.
Notice where you are,
and the more you do that,
the more you'll start to
feel presence in life.
Second, observe how you are.
What I mean by that is
observe how you're interacting
with the environment.
Observe how are you sitting right now?
How are you breathing right now?
How do you feel right now?
Observe that more consistently
to see how am I being
in this relationship right
now, with this person?
How am I speaking to them?
How do I probably sound to them?
Observing self in situations
starts bringing more
mindful mentality to
us, it also allows us,
over the long term, to
be more intentional.
Because you know what?
The more you observe
yourself, the more you start
seeing things you don't
like about yourself.
Gosh, I don't like how I talk to her.
I don't like how I'm missing
my children even being in
the room with me, because
I'm not paying attention.
I don't like how I feel continually,
I'm always anxious and negative.
It all comes...
Improvement from there
begins by observing it,
paying attention to it.
- My uncle always told me
something early in my life
which stuck with me, which
is that while you're on
the journey, you have to
disconnect from the end goal.
Because if you're just
focused on some end goal,
then you might get there,
but it will be hard
to progress past that
because you're so focused
on that one destination
that it's like you know,
you maybe forget everything in between.
And maybe you could've
done more in between.
He always told me, just
be here, right now,
live right now.
- In the moment.
- And do the best you can right now,
don't worry about what that end goal is.
It's great to have goals,
it's great to have dreams,
but it's just like you
get too attached to it,
and sometimes it can be
a self destructive thing.
So I mean, I just kind of try and progress
as much as I can, like right now.
- Most people have good, great goals.
I want to increase my
income, and lose weight,
and get out of debt, and be
thin, and happy, and healthy,
and have a wonderful family.
But then they decide, but before I start,
I'm going to take a vacation
to a beautiful place
called Someday Isle.
(audience laughing)
And in my estimation,
80% of the population
lives on Someday Isle
Someday I'll lose some weight,
and someday I'll read that
book and listen to that program,
and join the S Network,
and someday I'll get out of debt,
and someday I'll increase my income,
but it's always someday I'll.
If you want to be a great
success there's one simple rule
is vote yourself off the island for life.
If you decide you're going
to do something, do it.
You know what, they've done
dozens and dozens of studies
over the years, they find
that there's one major
difference between successful people
and unsuccessful people.
Is successful people launch, they start,
they get on with it, they just do it.
Unsuccessful people get the same ideas and
the same information, but
they've always got an excuse
for not starting.
- You're a guru of time management
and getting things done,
so give us the lay of the land,
and then we'll do a little deep dive.
- You ready?
- Yes, I'm ready for this.
- Your head is for having
ideas, not for holding them.
That's it.
- That's it?
- If you get that, you now
have the key to keeping
creative space in your brain,
to be able to have a lot more room,
to be a lot more creative
and a lot more fun,
fulfill your life a lot better.
Most people are walking,
most 99.999% of people
are still walking around
with the constipated psyche,
with all the stuff
they're trying to manage,
keep track of, remember,
remind themselves about,
whatever, and that is so suboptimal.
- My mouth is open because I just got it
in that one sentence,
how profound that is,
and I think about, you know,
you want to say, basically...
Say it again.
- Your head's for having
ideas, not for holding them.
- Your head is for having
I'm guessing that's getting
retweeted around the world.
- I need cat food should
pop into your head once.
If it pops in twice,
you're not handling your
appropriate engagement
with your cat or it's food.
- Cat food.
(man laughing)
- I mean, why have an idea twice?
The reason you do, and the
reason things pop into your head,
for the most part, is
simply because you're not
getting appropriately engaged
with whatever that thing is,
and it's got you, as
opposed to you got it.
- I love it.
- So interesting, you
have to learn the skill,
and what I just discovered and developed,
and really recognized,
I didn't make it up,
this is nothing new.
- Sure, this is humanity.
- Well, yeah, what I did was make explicit
what we implicitly do to get things done.
But the truth is that you
actually have to use our mind
to get stuff off your mind.
So a lot of people, I want to
have a clear head go all mmm,
or drink, or do something
to clear your head,
as opposed to wait a minute,
why is this on my mind?
And what do I need to do
to get it off my mind?
And that actually requires thinking.
- Those are two very important questions.
- I know that's bad news for
everybody listening to this.
Thinking is required so that
your brain can actually think.
- Think less, feel more.
That is how to live moment to moment.
You see, the problem is
you think you have time.
(soft peaceful music)
Yeah, you do have a lot of time.
But your time is running
out, it's been running out.
So what are you going to do about it?
To live moment to moment,
you got to ask yourself,
what am I doing in this moment?
Some people say gosh, Ralph,
why do you make videos
on a Sunday?
On a Monday, on a Tuesday, on a Wednesday,
on a Thursday, on a Friday, on a Saturday?
Everyday, are you an alien?
Can I get a hello there?
Because I live moment to moment.
You see, the secret of
success is to never rest
on your (mumbles).
Some people say oh, great
job Ralph, great video.
I say which one?
I'm too busy in the here and now creating.
I ain't got time to look back.
Ain't nobody got time for that.
We're moving forward, we're elevating,
we're having a great time.
So once again, to live moment to moment,
occupy the present, but most of all,
(deep breathing)
breathe in that good (mumbles).
Have a beautiful day.
- So my take on this is I
think that entrepreneurs
are the most powerful people in the world.
Not just about money, and not
just about having strength,
which it is too, but power,
in terms of the ability
to influence change.
The ability to look at something
that we want to change,
that we are not happy with in the world,
and instead of just complaining about it,
we want to go and do something about it.
That's what entrepreneurs do.
Entrepreneurs are going to
solve all of the major problems
of the world because that's what we do.
And if you want to tap into that power,
if you want to be the game changer,
if you want to solve those big problems,
then you have to learn how to be present.
Stop getting distracted
and stop playing small.
Stop checking your Facebook
posts because you got
one extra like in the past hour
and it makes you feel good.
Stop looking at your email
and pulling out your phone
every time a new notification comes in.
These distractions are preventing you from
doing your life's work.
Stop playing small.
What am I doing right now?
I'm making this video for you.
What am I thinking about right now?
Making this video for you?
What do I hope to accomplish?
I hope that by watching this video,
something sparks in here that
helps you play a bigger game,
that makes you realize you're
getting distracted too much
and you're playing a smaller game,
you're not doing the thing
that you should be doing.
That's my sincere hope.
Did I accomplish that?
Maybe, if not, I need to work
harder, I got to focus more,
I got to get better at what I'm doing.
But what I'm not doing,
I'm not thinking about
what am I going to eat for dinner tonight?
last nights game and
how we won or lost,
I'm not thinking about
my Instagram feed and
seeing if I've got a couple extra comments
in the past 15 minutes.
Because when I do that,
then I'm not making a great video for you.
If I'm checked out and
thinking of something else,
then I'm not in the task
that I'm doing right now.
And that means I would be playing small.
Me not being present, me not
trying to reach my potential
is unacceptable.
I'd like you to take an audit of your day
and look at how many hours
in your day is actually
being spent being massively productive,
massively productive.
How many hours in your day?
It's not that you need to sleep less,
it's just in the hours that you are awake,
you need to work harder, you
need to be more productive,
and that frustrates me because
you have insane talent.
Because you have these ideas,
and you have an ability,
and you want to do something good,
and you want to have a big impact,
and you're sitting on it.
You're wasting your time,
you're checking your Facebook
and doing all these other things that
are getting in the way of
you doing something great.
Stop playing small.
So I'd like you to make a commitment.
I want you to make a commitment.
I want you to say to yourself
I'm going to stop playing small
and start being present.
I'm going to stop playing
small and start being present.
small and start being present!
Do that for the next 30 days and
the results will astound you.
Finally you'll be playing at a level
that you're capable of.
You'll be doing things
that you know you could do,
but never actually reached.
Stop playing small, start being present.
Believe.
(light drumming)
So thank you guys so much for watching.
I made this video because
my (mumbles) asked me to,
so if there's a topic
you'd like me to cover
in the next edition of Believe Life,
leave it in the comments below
and I'll see what I can do.
I'm also curious what point
did you learn from this,
that you're really going to take home
and apply to your life or to your business
to help you stay more present?
Leave it in the comments,
I'm curious to find out.
Finally, I want to give a quick
shout out to Roberto Blake.
Roberto, thank you so much
for, one, being in my book.
Your One Word is one of the
stories that I told in the book,
I appreciate you sharing
your awesome story,
but also for recently making
a video of you with the book,
and sharing it with your audience.
I really, really, really
appreciate it, man.
- First of all, I'm in
the book Your One Word
by my good friend Evan Carmichael.
You guys probably know who Evan is
if you're watching this channel.
He has one of the best
channels for entrepreneurship
and motivation out there.
- So thank you guys again for watching.
I believe in you, I hope you
continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is.
Much love, we'll see you soon.
(intense drumming)
- I don't like to think too far ahead.
- [Interviewer] So you haven't
thought alternate careers?
- No, I don't like thinking too far ahead.
People set like goals, long
distance goals and (beep),
that's too much for me.
I all ready feel like I'm living,
and then I just carry on day on day.
And I'll carry on day
by day, all ready living
the final goal, the goal of
being the world champion.
I all ready carry myself
like I'm the world champion,
I all ready speak like
I'm a world champion.
And that's it, I just carry on day by day.
So I'll take it as it comes.
Again, like I said, you were
asking me about the future,
I'll let you know a little bit closer.
You know what I mean?
All I can see right now is the
goal, that's all I can see.
- If you're an Olympic athlete
or something like that,
you get to the high, you
also have to peak at the time
it's an Olympic year.
You could be the fastest
runner in the world
and it's an off year.
And so you know, by the
time you get to the Olympics
three years later, you aren't anymore.
So there's a lot of luck
involved in things in the world.
I've never lived my life
thinking about my next job
because I was always in
the last job I could have
as far as I could tell.
And I think it's a huge
advantage for you to live
in the moment and not
to be seething too much.
I mean, obviously, you plan,
even though your plans never work out,
but if you want, the
secret is to do a great job
with what you're doing.
What you should do is
you should perform as if
you were in your next
job, but not seethe with
the ambition to get
there, and project that.
You'll make people nervous as hell,
and you'll kill yourself.
When I was in high school,
because you've heard all
those advise reports.
I went Harvard College
at Harvard Law School.
When I went to the college from
the high school I came from,
it never dawned on me
that I'd get into that
kind of an Ivy League,
it just didn't happen,
but I applied, and I never
thought about it after really
I applied because it
just wasn't on my scope.
And so when I got a letter I got...
It didn't have any anxiety to it,
and when I got that letter
I just was like ecstatic.
And then my mind opened up.
But it was just like a great,
even the process of that was great.
When I was in college, and
I applied to Law School,
I went down to the mailbox everyday.
I knew the consequences of it,
I was with a bunch of people
who also wanted, and we're vying for it.
And I was like torturing myself over,
and I was imagining what if I do get it,
what if I don't get it,
what are the consequences
of getting it or not.
And I tell you, you know,
it effected my life,
it effected, you know, the functionality.
That's a difference.
If you could approach every
opportunity like I did
the college one, you'll be
better and you'll be happier.
And if you live the life
tormented about what
are my prospects or the next one,
when life is random and
there's some chance involved in
things, you're going to be tortured.
- I've had seasons where I've
had the worst surgeries ever.
I've been through, I've
had seven surgeries,
and that alone, you know, you
ask yourself time and time
again, how do you bounce back from that,
year end and year out.
But I've always used it
as taking that time to
strengthen myself, I never knew
I was going to play 17 years.
Who could've ever thought that?
When you come into the
league you don't say,
you know what, I'm going to play 17 years.
And you don't even think of it that way,
you just say I'll take it year by year.
And that's what I try to tell kids,
don't move to next year too fast.
Just like don't go to tomorrow too fast,
deal with today, deal with right now.
We've been in the locker
room and we have practice,
and I'm like listen, put the phones down,
because these moments
going to go too fast.
And when they're gone, they're gone.
So before you look up,
you're in two, three, five,
seven, 10, 12, if you make it that long.
Because most of them don't.
Just like you spoke about earlier,
most of these young babies
never see five years,
never see seven years,
nevertheless a 10 year career.
You try to prepare them to
understand what the moment
actually feels like,
and that's why I think,
honestly, why my career lasted so long,
because I always lived in the moment.
Nothing else mattered to me,
and I was selfish at times,
even towards my family,
nothing else mattered
when it came to that.
When it came to that I was dialed in.
It's a heck of a blessing to be here, now,
I'm walking, I'm healthy.
- Still making an impact?
- Absolutely, so I just tell people,
I don't know how long,
whoever's going to play,
but I will say enjoy every moment.
Don't rush too fast,
take care of your years,
but go year by year, go day
by day, go hour by hour,
go minute by minute.